[Musica]
non ho mai visto piovere plastica dal
cielo e non ho mai visto plastica
crescere sugli alberi eppure spesso ciò
che vedo è contenuto nella plastica e
ciò che mangio e avvolto nella plastica
e molti eroi di randi poi diranno bella
scoperta
per me lo è stato lo è stato perché
pensavo che isole di plastica
le tre shinan fossero lontano anni luce
dal posto in cui vivo dal posto in cui
vivete né dal posto in cui viviamo
eravamo a fare kite surf in adriatico
d'inverno una grande mareggiata e sotto
un cielo plumbeo a un certo punto sulla
battigia si palesarono una dozzina di
tartarughe tartarughe enormi bellissima
tartarughe morte
se oggi siamo qui a parlare è per
quell'evento che fu tanto traumatizzante
quanto illuminante allo stesso tempo
all'inizio cominciai a chiedermi ma cosa
accade perché nessuno si accorge di ciò
che sta accadendo perché nessuno fa
nulla per risolvere il problema è prima
di tutto cosa posso fare io per
risolvere questo tipo di problema la mia
idea è stata quella di di mettere
assieme quelle che erano le mie passioni
la tecnologia e il design e molti si
chiederanno come potranno mai tecnologie
e design risolvere questo tipo di
problema probabilmente la mia idea non
risolverà il problema ma spero che sia
uno stimolo per tutti voi affinché
qualcosa possa cambiare
tutto iniziò con un piccolo esperimento
fatto con dei con dei bambini in un
asilo
andai da loro e fece loro una proposta
ragazzi facciamo una cosa disegna temi
vostri supererò e tornerò da voi
tra tre giorni con una sorpresa
incredibile
neanche il tempo di finire la frase
inondarono di foglietti di carta pieni
di scarabocchi con tutti i loro super
eroi rappresentati raccolti tutti i
fogli e disse a loro ci vediamo tra tre
giorni ma dichiara ancora un'altra cosa
tornate a casa mettete da parte tutte le
bottiglie di plastica che utilizzerete
in questi giorni e riportate mela
rimasero un po basiti alla mia richiesta
e tre giorni dopo i ritornai all'asilo a
fare una chiacchierata con loro tutti
avevano portato dalle bottiglie di
plastica 345 presi le bottiglie e feci
vedere a loro come una bottiglia di
plastica può essere ridotta in tanti
piccoli pezzettini di plastica e come
tanti piccoli pezzettini di plastica
attraverso
un marchingegno un macchinino che ho
fatto in casa con un'elettronica da 20
euro cioè una spesa veramente abbastanza
abbordabile da tutti come quei frammenti
di plastica possono diventare un
filamento di plastica non dimenticherò
mai il loro volto e il loro stupore nel
vedere che quel filamento di plastica si
era poi trasformato nei loro supereroi
che loro avevano disegnato ho utilizzato
tutto ciò che loro mi avevano dato per
realizzare i loro giochini i loro super
eroi utilizzando una stampante 3d
molti di voi conoscono la stampa 3d solo
sotto alcuni aspetti
parliamo in effetti di una tecnologia
molto complessa e che spesso viene
ricordata più per il mondo dei maker che
per ciò che effettivamente si può fare
con questo tipo di tecnologie
parliamo di manifattura additiva
manifattura additiva perché additivi
mani factoring vuol dire sovrapporre
strato su strato rispettando i pieni ei
vuoti delle geometrie una geometria una
tecnologia che si potrebbe definire a
scarto zero perché fino ad oggi abbiamo
realizzato oggetti partendo da un pieno
e andando a buttare via tutto ciò che
non serviva per avere alla fine
l'elemento finito sprecando risorse e
anche tempo le tecnologie additive
applicate a ciò di cui abbiamo parlato
prima
potrebbero essere per me la soluzione
del problema
l'idea principale di utilizzare una
tecnologia scarto 0 e di riutilizzare le
plastiche e finalizzata a portare i
cittadini a recuperare le plastiche
tutto ciò che loro producono per
realizzare ad esempio l'arredo urbano
delle proprie città
provate a immaginare i parchi con delle
panchine realizzate in stampa 3d
provate a immaginare ai corpi
illuminanti delle strade realizzati
attraverso il recupero dei materiali
plastici prodotti dai cittadini stessi
provate a immaginare a tutte le
implicazioni che ciò avrebbe non solo
dal punto di vista economico per lo
smaltimento e recupero delle plastiche
ma anche del punto di vista della salute
dei cittadini
probabilmente i nostri figli e le
generazioni a venire
potrebbero non ammalarsi per
inquinamento la plastica è un'altra
delle opportunità da non sottovalutare
si potrebbe partire dal
a pensare al co design al ri progettare
la città e farlo insieme
perché no coinvolgere i cittadini anche
in questo
uno spazio urbano vissuta dai cittadini
riprogettata dai cittadini stessi
quindi ri progettare assieme i giochi di
progettare insieme un arredo urbano per
il parco di progettare assieme alla
panchina o qualsiasi altro elemento che
venga in mente coinvolgere i cittadini
nella realizzazione di nuovi spazi
quando ho iniziato a pensare a questo
progetto ea lavorare sul progetto mi
sono scontrato con tutto ciò che la
burocrazia
tutto ciò che il mondo che riguarda il
solo la raccolta lo stoccaggio ma anche
la trasformazione dei rifiuti e pensava
un'utopia
oggi non è più così non è più così
perché negli anni ho maturato la
convinzione che per cambiare il mondo e
per fare cose grandi
non servono solo soldi ma servono prima
di tutto buone idee è una mente libera e
se non qui a condividere con voi questa
idea affinché ciò che la volontà di
coloro che decidano non porterà avanti
potrà essere portata avanti da coloro
che crederanno in un progetto che ha
come scopo non un mero interesse
economico ma il bene comune è l'amore
per il bello si dice che alcune cose
cambiano le vita no in effetti con la
tartaruga mi ha un po cambiato la vita
altre cose però la vita ce l'ha
migliorano la mia vita è migliorata da
quando ricominciato a sognare
quindi ricominciamo a sognare si può
fare grazie
[Applauso]